okay toxic avengers accumulate
i like to call this meeting to order
first i would like to thank admiral
murica
for his tireless work to remove all the
asbestos from the cafeteria
job well done soldier however bulk i
hear you cause substantial damage on our
last field mission
bulk just trying to save peoples from
killer robot
peoples that doesn't explain the
devouring of every bagel and donut shop
in brooklyn
oh folks sorry go fix it
folks just really like donuts and bagels
i have arrived the meeting can start now
the meeting started five minutes ago
as scheduled hey relax black meadow
let let man come sit next to you you'll
feel better about this
at no time yeah about that lead man
we're gonna have to do something about
that led is toxic to the humans you are
saving what no way eye patch this is my
lead suit the ladies
dig it hey it protects me
i don't have to worry about x-rays or
nuclear radiation
how can it hurt those humans i'm sorry
i didn't create the laws of the universe
you need to work with professor plumbing
here to recreate the newer safer version
of yourself
further instructions are on your ship
hey i'll show this professor plumbum
that i'm
fine just the way i am lead man ain't
gonna change
no sir
this message will self-destruct in 10
seconds
i don't want to go to some museum to
find a flower painting are you kidding
me i'm a superhero flowers
i wasn't even singed by that go led
powers
those flowers sure are pretty yes there
are 82 of them
all are deadly they're flowers they're
made of
lead oh yeah i hear there's a
lead problem i'm led man i'm professor
plumbum
professor plumbub in the library with a
lead pipe
that was professor plum i am professor
plum bum
the lead pipes are involved in lead
poisoning uh
i'm confused poisoning lead no no no
i'm the medicine you need baby that's
not surprising that you're confused
look lead man this is serious for both
of us
we have to recreate you you cannot
continue to contact the humans in your
current condition
what do you mean look at this suit isn't
it amazing you can't mess with
perfection
let's start at the beginning
um okay where are we now we're on the
periodic table of elements
and i thought i was supposed to have the
superpowers led is element number 82
with the symbol
pb it's a soft silver bluish metal that
quickly turns to a black color when
exposed to air
lead is a very useful metal because
number one
it has a low melting point melting point
is the temperature at which a solid
melts to a liquid
lead can be melted into a liquid at much
lower temperatures than other metals
and then made into the desired shape so
i better knock it off with the fire soon
number two it is malleable that is easy
to form into different shapes
i can be flat like aluminum foil
i could be long and thin like a pipe
or i could be round like a ball any
shape really
number three lead is also very stable
over time and resists
corrosion the gradual wearing away by
reacting with other chemicals it's
exposed to
i am lead man that is great these
properties have made lead very useful to
mankind throughout history
to its detriment as we'll see in a bit
elemental lead led just by itself is
extremely rare in nature
lead compounds mixtures of lead and
other elements are found in the earth's
crust
the part that we can walk on and are
still rare oh yeah
i'm a rare bird so why is it a problem
to humans if it's so rare
like me lead is one of the easiest
metals to separate from other metals in
compounds mined out of the earth's crust
archaeological research has identified
lead mines dating back to 6 000 years
ago
even before these mines lead compounds
were used by ancient peoples
lead sulfate a black compound was used
as eyeliner in the stone age
lead oxide yellow and red in color was
used to glaze pottery in 5000 bc
and pure lead figurines have been
excavated from egyptian ruins dating to
4000 bc
along with weights vessels and other
metal work lead coins have been found
dating to 3 500 bce from both assyria
and china
romans took lead use to new depths
with the manpower to extract pure lead
from mines and great engineering
the romans used lead pipes in their
aqueducts water bridges
to deliver waters to the city remember
let's chemical symbol
it's pb the latin word for lead was plum
bum and the modern word plumber comes
from this word
well that really means you're lead woman
don't fill yourself with hate for lead
you need to be more
malleable lead is sometimes called the
roman medal they use lead in all facets
of their lives
from cursed tablets sheets and bath to
let compounds in their makeup and paint
products as well
see the roman empire glorified lead and
nothing bad ever happened to them
you can't have too much lead in addition
to the pipes
most households had pots and drinking
vessels made from lead
lead in its compounds have a sweet taste
the romans used lead acetate as a food
seasoning
and as a wine preservative they also
concentrated grape juice into syrup by
boiling it in lead pots
the acid from the juice would have
caused lead to leech into the syrup
so the humans liked lead it was easy to
work with they used it everywhere
how cool is that one small problem
lead in its compounds are toxic to
humans and other animals on earth
yeah toxic what's that mean toxic means
poisonous a substance causing or capable
of causing death
or illness if taken into the body
while crying isn't gonna help your toxic
little problem
fine how does it get in there are three
ways things can be taken in
or absorbed by the human body number one
through their skin
when they touch things number two
through their stomachs
and intestines when they eat and number
three through their lungs
when they breathe i thought those states
protected the humans like my lead suit
protects me
that's true for many things but each of
these is made up of living cells
these cells absorb things from the
environment and the bloodstream
the lung and intestinal cells will also
absorb the lead what about the skin
isn't that stuff dead the skin cells are
truly more protective cells
and in the case of lead do not absorb
much lead just touching a lead object is
not going to poison the human what about
eating it
that sounds bad once eaten 20 to 50
percent of the lead eaten will be
absorbed into the bloodstream
of the human breathing it is worse of
the lead breathed in from the air
nearly 100 percent of the lead is
absorbed into the bloodstream
oh what does that mean all right if
there were 10 grams of blood in the room
with you
and you ate it you would absorb two to
five grams of the lead
into your bloodstream if you breathed it
in nearly all 10 grams of the lead would
be absorbed into your bloodstream
the dose was the same 10 grams but the
amount in the body is different
because of how it was taken in another
important point
children absorb more than adults so now
it's in their blood
how does it poison them once in the
bloodstream the lead can travel to all
parts of the body
it has different effects depending upon
which organ of the body it is affecting
the primary target is the nervous system
when lead is absorbed by the cells of
the brain
it causes permanent damage including
decreased
intelligence
memory loss paralysis and decreased
social skills
hey we're talking about humans here let
doesn't affect
my species but why does it target the
human brain
the brain is sensitive to lead a tiny
amount causes big
problems other cells can handle the lead
a little bit better
give me the rest of it what else does it
do in the guts lead poisoning causes
cramping
pain and constipation in the blood
itself there are low levels of healthy
red
blood cells the ones that transport
oxygen to all the cells of the body
poison humans also show reduced appetite
and feel tired
it damages cells everywhere in the lungs
the kidneys and the reproductive system
how much does it take to poison a human
there is no safe dosage of lead a high
dose all at once results in
acute lead poisoning with symptoms
affecting the neurological and digestive
systems the most
long-term exposure to lower doses
results in chronic lead poisoning
the cells are being damaged all over but
at a slower rate
so the human doesn't appear to be
poisoned because it happens over a long
time
even the romans knew about acute lead
poisoning from observing their minors
painters and metal workers coming down
with a disease
didn't know about the chronic poisoning
though so the romans stopped using it
right
yeah right do you always follow the
speed limit in your spaceship
knowing about the dangers and not
engaging in them are two different
things
and where are we now the dark ages of
course
lead mining and use were much lower
during this time period
up until the 19th century one notable
exception was the mechanical movable
type printing press
gutenberg combined several existing
technologies to create this press
that used lead-based printing blocks
lead was melted with tin and antimony
and poured into molds to form the
printing blocks
that was also used to make bullets and
waits for fishing remember lead can be
melted
over a regular wood fire and then melded
into the desired shape
those workers don't look so good i
thought lead wasn't absorbed well
through the skin
that's true the danger comes from
breathing the dust coming off the items
as they are handled or heated
and eating small amounts from your hands
and lips if they are not washed off
after working with the metal
so humans are sickened by me because of
small amounts of lead dust
coming off of me that can't be true i
use a dandruff reducing shampoo
yes the lead dust coming off of you is a
possibility for the sickness that could
happen
that's why we have to recreate you
where are we now focus we're in the
1800s ah
so when are we now i thought i was the
superhero hey i want one of these time
buttons you have here
focus focus the industrial revolution
brought with it mining at levels never
seen before
led was easily accessed and cheap with
many industrial uses
just as in roman times people used it
for pipes or to connect copper pipes
together
as in roman times usually as long as the
water is flowing
very little lead from the pipes gets
into the water
one of the largest problems of modern
times came with the use of
lead carbonate which looks like this
it was used to produce bright white
color in indoor house paints just as
artists before had prized lead carbonate
for the same quality
lead-based paint was used to paint
virtually all indoor spaces
beginning in the 1800s until the 1950s
before completely phasing out by about
1977 in the united states
this paint is toxic when eaten
wait who's eating paint remember how the
romans use lead acetate as seasoning on
their food
lead tastes sweet to humans
young children may find paint chips on
the floor eat them
and then look for more people of all
ages may possibly breathe in the paint
dust as well
wait wait hold it so now the humans are
surrounded by lead
in their houses in a way but
it gets worse they're surrounded by it
drink it and eat it how does it get
worse
henry ford changed the world with the
creation of the first moving assembly
line car
the model t this made cars affordable to
working families not just the very rich
the other car companies quickly moved to
copy the assembly line and make money
selling cars to everyone competitors
developed fancier cars
but their engines had problems engineers
found adding a lead compound
tetraethyl lead fixed the engine's
problems
okay but correctly if i'm wrong i don't
think people on this planet eat carbs
tetraethyl lead is also known as tell
and these tell additives are extremely
toxic to produce and car exhaust emitted
the lead product directly into the
atmosphere remember the body absorbs up
to 100
of the lead that is breathed in so
inhaling a low dose of lead will cause
more problems than eating the same dose
of lead it then
causes all those health problems we
talked about earlier
this is not looking good for the humans
at all calm down
there is good news the toxic effects
were recognized and legislation was
passed to phase-out tel additives
starting in 1973 and ending in 1986 in
the u.s
all leaded gas additives were banned in
the u.s by the end of 1995.
most countries today ban lighted gas for
automobiles the levels of lead in the
human bloodstream dropped by 78
from 1978 to 1991 after leaded gas was
phased out
what about those lead pencils humans use
what's up with that
so-called lead pencils actually use
graphite a form of carbon that is
non-toxic to humans
it has its name because originally they
thought graphite was a form of lead
oh bummer i told this girl one time that
i made the pencil i gotta make a call
so where does that leave the humans
today
lead paint may be found in buildings
built before 1978
but it is safe if it is not peeling or
powdery
similarly some houses contain lead pipes
leaded fuel is banned in most countries
and there is reduced lead pollution in
the air lead is still used for many
industrial processes
and products and lead mining and other
industries continue to expose workers
and communities to airborne let the two
main uses today
are lead-based car batteries and x-ray
and radiation protection
other uses include bullets and other
ammunition use in glass and ceramics
metal molds sheet lead used in buildings
roofs to surround cables
and sometimes it gets included in
jewelry paint on toys
cars houses etc homeopathic medicine
fishing equipment candy remember the
sweet taste and metal decorations
so what did we learn today the very
qualities that make lead so useful to
humans
also make it extremely deadly exactly
acute lead poisoning by mining painting
plumbing and using the printing press
was known in ancient times the effects
of chronic lead poisoning by the use of
lead pipes vessels paint and other lead
compounds over a lifetime
was only described in recent times
researchers continue to study the levels
of lead and to support legislation to
protect humans and the planet earth
with some simple precautions humans can
limit their exposure to lead in their
daily lives
so humans protect yourselves from lead
number one don't play by old paint you
can eat it or inhale it
don't let young children touch or play
with it either also
don't play the dirt that may be
contaminated with old paint
and it's gross it's gross
stop it and number two flush old pipes
with
cold water for 30 seconds if the water
is being used for drinking or eating
this allows any lead that may have come
off the pipes into the water
to flow out of the pipe and into the
drain water that is flowing through the
pipes not sitting in them
is very unlikely to be contaminated with
lead number three
use caution when buying kid jewelry or
toys or even candy manufactured in
countries that do not have strict laws
on the use of lead
look for lead-free or non-toxic labels
different countries have different laws
on lead and its use
number four thoroughly wash your hands
after handling
any lead solids after science class
hunting fishing
painting or handling pipes number five
recycle car batteries limit the amount
of lead that gets into your local
ecosystem
and number six don't go to my apartment
right now
i i have a lot of cleaning to do
apparently
i've learned a lot today that don't
don't don't come by
we're gonna move the party to next
weekend ladies
anything else yeah humans uh wash your
hands
before eating or drinking leave your
shoes at the front door
um don't wear a lead suit all the time
it's okay for your dentist to put one on
for x-rays
the lead in those aprons is completely
contained and can't leak out knowledge
is power
in this case protective power lead man
lead man yeah no uh that's
uranium plutonium fusion man now thank
you oh man
this has been a presentation of the u.s
national library of medicine division of
specialized information services
visit the environmental health student
portal for more information on lead
dismiss soldier
you